a new book is Fanning the flames over
whether President Trump obstructed
justice in the Special Counsel
investigation The Guardian reports the
book's author Michael Wolfe says Robert
Muller had drawn up an indictment
against the president a three count
indictment but that's not what Muller's
people say and this author has been
called out like this before
here's Fox News media analyst and host
of Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz Michael
Wolfe is coming out with another book
one whose most inflammatory allegation
has already been denied by Robert
Muller's office the Guardian which
obtained an advance copy of seized Trump
on your fire says wolf makes the
explosive charge that Muller drew up a
three count obstruction of justice
indictment against Donald Trump before
deciding to shelve it but Muller
spokesman Peter Carr told the Guardian
the documents that you've described do
not exist wolf was dogged by controversy
even before he published his previous
blockbuster fire and fury which was on
target in revealing the backstab began
leaking in the Trump White House but
journalists and politicians pointed out
numerous errors such as saying CNN had
published parts of the so-called steel
dossier when it was actually BuzzFeed
the president called fire of fury full
of lies and said he never spoke to Wolf
for the book which the author disputed I
absolutely spoke to the president
whether he realized it was an interview
or not the fact that there was a claim
that the president didn't know who John
Boehner was is pretty ridiculous Wolfe
acknowledged in that book that several
sources gave him accounts that were
boldly untrue or contradicted each other
but that he published them anyway in a
very different clash over credibility
Ian Bremmer an NYU professor in Time
magazine editor at large tweeted this
made-up quote President Trump in Tokyo
Kim jong-un is smarter and would make a
better president than sleepy Joe Biden
Bremer was reacting to Trump agreeing
with the North Korean dictator that
Biden has a low IQ and drew this
presidential denunciation this is what's
going on in the age of fake news people
think they can say anything and get away
with it Bremer who had defended the
fictitious quote as satire but kind of
plausible now says it was meant in jest
I should have been clearer my apologies
such incidents give the president more
munition to slam the press now wolf will
undoubtedly get enormous publicity for
his new anti Trump book which in this
polarized environment could drown out
even a flat denial from Bob Muller bread
how are thanks